-Thank you so much.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
-You are my -- You are my "FIFA"
player when I play video games.
-You play "FIFA"?
[ Laughter ]
-I play you.
Yeah, you're my guy.
-Okay.
-So, I just want to say
thank you for all the wins.
-Any goal -- Any goals?
-Yeah, fantastic.
Oh, are you kidding me?
Yeah.
"Kane!"
I get it all the time, yeah.
That's --
You're one of the top
soccer players in the world,
you're captain
of the England national team.
You've won countless awards.
There's an exhibit about you
at the Museum of London
right now.
-That's right, yeah.
-When you were a kid, did, like,
your coaches think like,
"Oh, this -- this kid, Harry,
is gonna be a superstar?"
-No, I don't think so.
I don't think --
I mean,
I was good when I was younger,
but I don't think I was
the best player on the team.
And I really had
to kind of work hard
to kind of prove people wrong.
But I think that's what made me
kind of who I am today
and got me to the level
I got to,
'cause that kind of self-belief,
that drive, that determination.
And that's kind of what the
museum's there, to kind of --
kids can go and look at that
and see my journey,
and hopefully, one day, they can
aspire to be where I am.
-What gets you inspired?
What -- what --
What do you watch,
or what do you read,
where you go like,
"Oh, that's inspires me"?
-Yeah, I mean, one thing
that did inspire me kind of
growing up was actually
a Tom Brady documentary.
I was -- I was away
at another club, on loan,
and kind of I wasn't
getting the team,
and it was kind of that period
in my -- I was 18 years old --
it was like,
"If I can't play here,
how can I play for my team?"
Tottenham, at the time.
Come across this documentary
on YouTube.
It was -- I think it was called
"The Brady 6."
It was kind of about how he got
picked in the 6th round,
and then become who he become,
one of the greatest
sportsmen ever.
And it just gave me a real
belief that it was possible
for me to go on and kind of
have that -- have that career.
And, yeah, thankfully,
I was able to do that.
-It's a boost, yeah.
And you -- you've gotten to be
friends with Tom Brady now,
right?
-Yeah, I mean, we --
we've got in touch.
I mean, I was kind of following
him on Instagram,
and he kind of commented
on one of my --
my pictures when I --
-You slid into his DMs?
[ Laughter ]
-I slid into his DMs and --
No, he was a great guy.
We kind of got talking.
I kind of --
I'm -- I'm an NFL fan,
so I was kind of wishing him
luck for --
for the season and stuff.
And, yeah, just kind of grew a
relationship from there, really.
-Did you know that he was gonna
come out of retirement?
-I mean, I wasn't 100% sure.
He actually come to --
to a game,
one of our games in the U.K.
about two months ago.
It was actually the day before
he announced
he was coming back to play.
And I asked him, I was like,
"Oh, how you getting on?
How's retirement treating you?"
And his face just was like, "Mm,
I'm not sure if I'm ready yet."
So, I mean, he didn't, like,
say he wasn't --
-Yeah, you were like,
"Wait a second.
Did he just say
what I think he did?"
-Yeah, pretty much.
So, I mean, yeah.
So, next day, he announced it,
which was --
I thought it was great,
you know?
It's great.
I love watching him.
-Yeah.
-And it's great for the sport.
-If ever emergency need be,
and they need a kicker
for the Buccaneers,
or the New York Giants
or the Jets...
-Yeah.
-...could you step in?
Would you be a good kicker?
Could you kick field goals?
-I mean, I feel like I could.
I'd put myself up there,
for sure.
-Yeah.
We're -- like to --
I don't have any tie-in
with any organization,
but we would love to welcome you
to New York.
[ Laughter ]
Play for either one.
But you actually
brought us a video
of you actually making
a 50-yard field goal?
-Yeah, this is in New York,
as well, yeah.
-How did you end up doing this?
-This was on preseason
with our team,
and we kind of -- I was doing
something with the Giants.
And, yeah, kind of just
kicking some field goals
and knocked a few in, yeah.
-Let's take a look at this.
Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You booted it!
Oh, my gosh.
-Yep.
-We have an all-military
audience tonight,
and I wanted to ask you,
is it true that you trained
with the Royal Marines
for the last World Cup?
-I did, yes.
So, before the last World Cup,
our coach took us down
to the Royal Marines.
And was like, "Yeah, we're gonna
be here for a few days,"
and kind of get together
and do some team bonding.
And I loved it, if I'm honest.
I really enjoyed it.
We kind of --
They took our phones away,
put us in the uniform,
kind of took us straight out
to kind of this --
in the middle of a forest,
and we learned how to kind of
put up the tents they sleep in
and kind of cooking on the fire.
-The soccer team?
-Yeah, we was all there
with the Marines,
and, yeah, was doing that.
Slept over.
We done some of that
tactical training in the woods
with some --
Yeah, and then a three-mile hike
at 5:00 a.m. the next morning.
We done it all.
-I couldn't do any
of those things
that you just said.
I couldn't set up a tent if --
Yeah, no.
-No, we done it all.
We done kind of
all the training, the --
I think they called it
sheep's dip, when you go under
the tunnel in the water
and everything like that.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah, it was really cool.
We was grateful, kind of
that team bonding aspect.
We were together for three days,
getting to know them.
They was getting to know us.
As a team, we was together.
And I think it really helped us
in that World Cup.
-Right now,
you're four goals away
from being England's top
goal-scorer of all-time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, what --
What does that --
I mean, how are you feeling
going into this --
this year's World Cup?
-Yeah, I mean, I'm excited.
You know, the last World Cup
was really special.
We got to the semifinal,
which was the first semifinal
we'd got to in like
30 years as a nation.
And the country
was going pretty mad.
But, of course, we fell
that one step short,
so I'm really looking forward
to this one.
We have a great team.
Really good players,
really good coach.
We've been kind of building
nicely to -- to this World Cup.
And I'm really
looking forward to it.
And hopefully, yeah,
can try and break that
goal record whilst we're there.
-Wow, Harry Kane.
We -- you know, I was gonna
challenge you to something,
some type of --
but you would just
crush me in anything.
But then I go, "Oh,
this might be a good idea."
Would you -- Would you like to
play me in a game of foosball?
-Let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A mini --
a mini foosball table here.
-Have you been --
Have you been practicing?
-I have not been practicing, no.
Let me just see what it's like.
Okay, good.
All right, that's me there.
First one to 2 wins?
Is that okay?
-Okay, let's do it, yeah.
-All right, buddy.
Good luck.
No -- No hard feelings, right?
-All the best, yeah?
-Yeah.
[ Drumroll ]
♪♪
-Oh.
-Oh. My God.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're that fast?
All right.
1-0.
-1-nil.
-That was a good shot.
-Thank you.
That's a striker, right?
-Yeah, that was a striker.
Okay, ready?
♪♪
Huh! No!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I did it myself.
I can't even win at that!
I can't even win in this game!
Harry Kane, everybody!
The champ.
You can watch him compete in
the World Cup later this year.